make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and DC has surprised the world
by releasing DC unkillable as the third
part digitally which is cool so the
little guys who saw the first two parts
of our unkillable story which really we
we probably cover that a couple months
ago because you know everything was shut
down with regards to obvious reasons we
kind of had this weird scenario right
the the main DC uncured I guess the main
beasts east story follow the various
characters right Batman Superman Wonder
Woman those kind of characters the the
core of the Justice League more or less
unkillable 'he's answer the question of
what happened to the Red Hood right
where's Jason Todd been all this time
and it kind of followed more of the the
villains and various people now as we
expected when it came to the deceased
line of comics most of the characters
that we were introduced to died right
they were killed by by either the
anti-life equation or I guess they were
turned into monsters by the anti-life
equation or they were just outright
killed and so what we were left with was
this kind of ragtag group of villains
right you had creeper you had
Deathstroke you had cheetah you had Red
Hood you had Rose who was Deathstroke's
daughter you had Cassandra Cain and you
have Jim Gordon who's kind of here is
the sort of rallying point and really
he's the only true hero there and then
when we when we got to the last video we
essentially had this scenario where Bane
who was one of the guys who was here was
basically infected by the by the
anti-life equation and that's the one of
the worst things to have happen right
because while you do have people like
Solomon Grundy who's more than enough to
take Bane the reality is that Bane in
and of himself is still very capable not
only that we ended up seeing Bane
basically opening the floodgates to all
these you know anti life monsters that
are running around here and so what it
did is is where Bane was basically
immediately killed by Solomon Grundy it
does leave like all these various
monsters you know these various people
coming you're coming pouring in now when
this happens the initial question is
what do we do right because it's a
moment of panic it's a moment of kind of
shock like oh my god you know and and in
that moment Solomon Grundy's response is
run right as all these people come
pouring onto him Solomon Grundy's
response is just run now the cool thing
is that you have creeper who leaps in to
basically help pull Solomon Grundy out
of all these people so of course Solomon
Grundy continues to survive or that
appears to be the case and the idea of
Jim Gordon is okay then let's basically
turn this room into a kill box right and
as the smartest Roo is the smartest
thing possible because the doorway is so
small only so many people can fit
through it right so by default it really
kind of thins their numbers and this
a great opportunity for the various
characters to essentially shoot them as
they can the issue is they have a couple
different problems running against them
the first and most obvious is ammunition
right how much ammo do they have to hold
out and then on top of that just the
sheer weight and the sheer pressure of
all these people pushing against this
doorway it's gonna smash down the doors
and that's why we kind of get this this
really cool explanation of there's only
so much time that we can have here and
so essentially all they're really
dealing with this kill box is buying
time time for the kids to get out time
for everybody else to escape and of
course they'll end up following up and
the idea is to run to the two buses that
are available and the Batmobile right
you've got Red Hood basically you know
driving this this Batmobile and then
you've got Deathstroke driving one of
the buses and you've got Lady Shiva
driving the other bus and it's kind of a
cool thing because as they make their
way through what is up happening mirror
master shows up and this deceased story
and this is this was what's so cool
about this right this could happen
anywhere else in DC Comics but it
happened here and it's the reason why
Tom Taylor is such an amazing writer
because he's so good at taking a
character and then just kind of
elevating them and leaving you in this
spot where you're just kind of like man
this carrot is a lot cooler than I
thought they were as long as it's a
window or a mirror mirror master can
access it if you can see your reflection
he can pass through it and that's
exactly what happens here he enters the
rear-view mirror where Slade Wilson
where Deathstroke is driving the bus
you're essentially fighting for your
life right and like you're just fleeing
for your life and you're running so like
the emergency vehicles to get out of
there the last thing your gonna think
about is mirror master had come through
the the rear view mirror
and kill us right that's the last thing
that you're thinking of and that's
exactly what happens right mirror
masters hand comes flying through and
basically swipes hit at Deathstroke and
does manage to injure him Jim Gordon
ends up you know taking up the vehicle
in his stead it does result in them
crashing foot like Slade Wilson heels
you know almost immediately and that's
basically it like his response is okay
mirror master is here guys let's start
knocking out the windows and all that
kind of stuff but before that can happen
mirror master starts popping in and out
snatching up these young kids whisking
them away in order to consume them more
or less or turn them into anti life
zombies one of the young girls Matilda
starts to get yanked up and then cheetah
jumps in and basically takes out mirror
master with a quickness and this is
what's so cool is because when it comes
to this kind of story and we were
looking at this in DC proper right so
like basically any major DC story going
on right now cheetah might be a little
kind of wishy-washy
right but in this deceased landscape
there's no good guys and bad guys
anymore
there's just survivors and the more
people that are living the better of a
chance they have because there's safety
in numbers and so what their whole goal
here is essentially to head to the
Gotham Garden now if you guys recall
what the Gotham Garden is or Lowe's you
guys who do not recall we saw that in
the deceased story and the Gotham Garden
is essentially that giant garden that
poison ivy built right using all the
various plant life and plant matter that
was around there to create this
indestructible fortress in this area and
so following that you know what you have
here is literally just the bat the
Batmobile it's just like let's just plow
through here let's just blast do all of
this but it's suddenly an alarm cakes up
and Jason Todd picks up on the fact that
it's flying low and heading straight
towards them and so the initial response
of Rose is somebody's fired off a
missile what we're not finding out here
it's not a missile that's been fired off
by anybody it's Wonder Woman and I love
this because we get this amazing segment
here right we basically see cheetah just
kind of dive in and it's kind of nuts
because you have this kind of commentary
like this could have been the end right
all of this could have been the ending
of us but it wasn't because like cheetah
jumped and following cheetah then it was
creeper and then it was Solomon Grundy
and these three guys just jump in and
started taking it to Wonder Woman as
best they can
now River she's an Amazon right she's on
par with Superman in terms of strength
speed durability that kind of stuff the
best they can do is hold her off that's
that's the best they can do Solomon
Grundy out of all these guys Solomon
Grundy stands the best chance of being
able to do it because of just sheer
brute strength but at the end of the day
he's not the sharpest tool in the shed
right so it was easy for Wonder Woman to
outthink him
that's one of the the biggest
disadvantages that Solomon Grundy has
and so ultimately Slade Wilson comes up
with this idea because you end up having
all these guys fighting Wonder Woman and
then you've also still got that massive
army of the undead the response of Slade
Wilson is everybody get out of this
first bus going to the second I'm gonna
stay here I'm gonna drive this thing and
I'm gonna take out all of these undead
now lady she was initial response is
like this is stupid right there's no
reason for you to sacrifice your life
for like one person you know because
there's idea is to go get rose and try
to try to save the day the issue is that
as they're transitioning Cassandra Cain
is snatched up by one of these these
anti life monsters Lady Shiva goes out
in an uncharacteristic way and then
basically saves her daughter and that's
kind of the cool thing right because
again this whole like era of vendetta's
this whole of like you betrayed me you
left me hang in you know at some point
in time in our past best gone that
doesn't exist anymore it's just let's
just live
and that's that's why this story is so
incredibly good because it's like let's
just survive if that's all it really is
and so Lady Shiva and ampere senator
Cassandra Cain of course end up fighting
off these these armies of the undead and
it makes sense right lady she was a
deadliest woman in the world
Cassandra Cain's not too far behind it's
it's awesome to see the problem with
this is that as as Lady Shiva is making
her way back she's basically scratched
her or caught by one of these guys she
ends up managing to behead them but now
she's gonna transform and so basically
saying her piece to her daughter she
ends up just ripping her own heart out
and that's basically the end of her now
the reason why this is important is
because was it does is it gives a caveat
to how to destroy people right how to
destroy those individuals who are
basically Undead you can rip their
hearts out and that's the end of them
right you know it's kind of a cool thing
because following that the forces of
creeper and solomon grundy they all end
up being overwhelmed by Wonder Woman and
literally torn apart cheetahs neck is
broken the creepers head is ripped off
and Solomon Grundy's heart is pulled out
of his body and his organs are destroyed
right his organs are totally disrupted
and that's how Solomon Grundy can die
Solomon Grundy's organs being ripped out
of his body there's no healing factor
form there's they're they're not gonna
regrow or anything like that and it's
the exact same thing with Slade Wilson
right as Rose gets on the bus and and
her father basically instructs her to
leave that like you get this this super
amazing moment right Slade Wilson's like
this Last Man Standing unlike this
mountain of bodies and the the anti-life
monsters keep coming and he's just like
swiping away and like cutting them and
chopping their heads off and all that
kind of stuff and you get this really
amazing moment where it's like for a
time they thought that Slade Wilson was
unkillable no one could take him out
it's Slade Wilson at his finest right
just killing an army of monsters but
then out of nowhere
Wonder Woman shows up and that's the end
of Slade Wilson now the cool thing is
that following that Wonder Woman is up
grabbing the bus and whisking it up into
the air with the intention of dropping
it and like everybody's panicking
everybody believes are gonna die but the
moment before it hits they're all
suddenly rescued by Mary Marvel she
comes out of nowhere now here's the
thing Tom Taylor is a master at this he
is a master like this this is literally
a master class on how to just surprise
people right because we saw that when he
wrote injustice we've we've seen there
with all these different stories that he
wrote they're just a character comes out
of nowhere and it's a last person you
expect and like the the respective fan
base of that character it's just like
yeah that's exactly what this is right
like Mary Marvel just
Wizards out of nowhere in saves the day
and once once she basically takes out
Wonder Woman right like Wonder Woman's
totally incapacitated by Mary Marvel
that's the end of end of her Mary Marvel
really just starts talking to everybody
and saying like apparently Mary Marvel
was the one who saved these orphan kids
in the first place and trapped Billy
Batson in that room with everybody when
Billy was turned into a young kid when
he somehow reverted back whatever the
case was Billy Batson was basically put
inside that orphanage and locked in that
room and Mary Marvel didn't want Billy
to become Shazam and then uses powers to
terrorize the world now the other
question that we kind of have to ask
here is are there any other members of
the Shazam family here or is Mary the
only one left is there anybody else and
if there's not that what it means is the
totality of the power of Shazam is
within Mary Marvel but it's not spread
across anybody else it's completely in
her there are no reinforcements coming
there's no other members of the Shazam
family to save the day so again Mary
Marvel makes quick work of Wonder Woman
pretty fast right at the very least you
know basically sends her out sins are on
her way and she kind of talked about how
like she's been training with this kind
of ferocity right like she's got this
ferocity of Lady Shiva and Cassandra
came that she'd had enough of being
scared that normally Mary Marvel would
try to be kind and she would try to be
you know more tender and her approach in
terms of how she deals with villains and
this she just starts ripping Wonder
Woman to pieces she just takes it to her
as best she can't following that she
grabs the bus lifts it up into the air
and basically flies it inside the garden
of Gotham which makes a pathway for them
and as they get in there the kind of
response is okay be ready Wonder Woman's
going to get in here like she's she's
gonna enter this place and she's gonna
start tearing things up worse than
before because now she's pissed and now
she's got somebody like Mary Marvel to
contend with and the response from
poison ivy is no she cannot breach the
darkness and the reason why is because
dr. fate and John Constantine and
Zatanna and all these guys are here and
the entire place is magically protected
but that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to commerce explain make sure
you guys are the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]